in this video I want to talk a little
bit about the energy requirements of
translation so in translation we had a
bunch of different processes occur
namely initiation elongation and
termination but before we could even
have that we had to have the amino acyl
tRNA synthetase reaction occur which
activated the amino acid and charged the
tRNA so each activation step or or
charging step requires two ATP
equivalents and that's because we went
from an ATP to an a MP and a
pyrophosphate and the force the
pyrophosphate was hydrolyzed off into
two inorganic phosphates so that's the
equivalent of using two ATP's
initiation required one ATP equivalent
in which we use the GDP which was
hydrolyzed off into a GDP and an
inorganic phosphate the elongation
required to ATP equivalence there was
one GTP for the actual elongation step
in which we form the covalent bond
between the two amino acids and one GDP
one gtp required for translocation so
now each elongation step required to ATP
equivalence so each time you add an
amino acid it costs two ATP equivalents
termination required one ATP equivalent
a gtp was hydrolyzed off into a GDP and
an inorganic phosphate so if we know
this information how can we use that to
calculate the amount of energy or cost
to make a peptide chain so what if we
wanted to make an amino acid chain of
just four amino acids the hepatitis A
and above four amino acids how much
energy would that cost well each one of
these amino acids needs to be activated
so that would we have four of them times
two ATP equivalents because each step
will require two ATP equivalents
initiation only needs to happen once
right once we've initiated what we're
done so require one ATP
equivalent for initiation
now what about elongation well once
we've initiated it we have one amino
acid sitting in the peptide chain and
we're going to add 3 to it so that means
if we're going to add three of them then
we're going to have three elongation
steps so we have three elongation steps
times the energy requirement for each
step which is to equivalent so that'll
cost us six ATP once we've added all of
those we need to terminate the
translation and that's only going to
cost us one ATP equivalent so that total
there is 16 ATP so what about for a
peptide chain though with 30 amino acids
in length well in this case you would
have to have 30 times 2 for activation
each amino acid would need to be
activated so that would be 60 ATP their
initiation only would cost 1 ATP
termination would also only cost one ATP
in this case how I'm going to eat
elongation steps are we going to have
well if it's 30 we start off with one
amino acid and we're going to elongate
it by adding 29 amino acids so we're
going to have 29 times 2 which is 58 so
then if we add all this up to get to
total we get 120 ATP so that's how much
it would energy would cost to make a
peptide chain that was 30 amino acids
than like I hope that video was helpful
one last thing I'm a tutor if you live
in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email I move university a
gmail comm see the description below for
more details thank you for watching